do you know what the round is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones video
today I want to talk about brain stark
the night king and ultimately how their
conflict comes to an end
most of the main characters in Game of
Thrones are in a constant battle over
who they think should be seated on the
Iron Throne but bran stark and the
knight King have been engaging in a
battle of their own which does involve a
lot of dark magic even though Jon Snow
is the one that's leading the fight
against the night king bran stark is the
one who seems to have the closest
connection to him in fact brain stark
might be the only character that has
been touched by the night King and is
still able to talk about it Game of
Thrones has made it very clear that bran
stark in the night King shares some very
similar powers ever since bran was
marked by the night King in season six
this has made their connection with one
another even deeper
this allowed the night King to pinpoint
brain Stark's exact location and ever
since then the night King has been
moving full steam ahead season seven
ended with the night king bringing his
entire army south and now that brain is
in Winterfell this might be the night
King's next target brain stark might be
able to travel through time but he
cannot outrun the night King forever
fortunately for bran stark he is not the
only one it wants to stop the night king
most of Jon Snow's men are already in
the north and now that he has Daenerys
Targaryen on his side
Winterfell should be well protected by
the time the night King arrives but well
brain stark be ready give in brain
Stark's condition we know he will never
step foot on the battlefield
the type of service brain will provide
will take place somewhere else which is
inside of his head during season seven
we saw something that further hinted at
the mysterious connection between brain
stark and the night king we saw this
when bran sent out the Ravens to spy on
the night king when brain sent them into
the far north we were able to get a good
look at the size of the night king's
army but what happened next was very
interesting the night king could sense
Bryan's presence and that's when the
night king turned his head to the Ravens
when it happened
bran could no longer control the birds
and it even made him snap back into his
wheelchair I think this goes to show the
night King still has more power than
bran the night king can enter his
visions inside of the weirwood net and
he can even force him out of the animals
he's controlling the night king can
easily control his own powers because
he's had thousands of years to practice
Bryan has barely had enough time to
Train it was basically a crash course
the where would Ned most likely holds
the key to unlocking the night king
mystery with the use of the weirwood net
brand should be able to find the answers
he has been looking for but the only
problem is he doesn't know where to look
we have even heard Brian say this during
at least two different scenes the first
one I want to show you is actually from
a scene I played in my last video about
Benjen stark listen closely to what he
says he loves tree a tree even though I
didn't have time to learn I can't
control anything it was good to control
for the night king comes
as you can see Brian Stark has now
become the new three-eyed Raven but he
hasn't really had any time to learn
everything he is able to see things but
it's all in fragments he's not able to
control all the visions that are getting
thrown at him it's like one big
information dump and Brian has to try to
put the puzzle together
Benjen tells him you must learn how to
control it before the night King comes
so this is our first big clue in
defeating the night king when Brian
finally learns how to take control of
the flashbacks and visions he should be
able to see what needs to be done to win
now let's take a look at another scene
because almost the exact same thing is
said again you see as we get closer to
the end of the show they continue to
give us clues about what needs to be
done to stop the night king this next
scene actually gives us two clues
because the brain says something first
then he looks directly at the tree pay
very close attention I don't know what
that means it means I can see everything
everything that's ever happened to
everyone
everything that's happening right now
it's all pieces now fragments I need to
learn to see better when the long night
comes again I need to be ready so as you
can see this conversation was Sansa is
very close to the same conversation he
had with his uncle Benjen we know that
bran has now become the new three-eyed
Raven but he is still trying to figure
out how to interpret all these different
things he is being shown his uncle
Benjen told him you have to learn how to
control it before the night king comes
then brain says to sanso i need to learn
how to see better before the long night
comes when brain says I need to be ready
he looks at the weirwood tree so what
are they trying to tell us just like I
told you in my last video benjin
basically gave us the answer when he
told us this was good to control
for the night King comes
drink
[Music]
one way another it will find his way to
the will of men when he does you will be
there waiting for him and you will be
ready so we know brain will be ready
which means by the end of next season
bran will learn how to control all the
visions and flashbacks next season brain
stark will be at the height of his
powers it's going to take more than just
a simple sword fight to defeat the night
king but what is it that's inside of the
weirwood net that brain is so
desperately needing to learn what
possible answers are hiding inside of
those trees the answer must lie in the
past but what is it
how will bran know where to find it well
bran stark now has a secret weapon of
his own in his name is Samwell Tarly I
can see things that happen in the past I
can see things happening now all over
the world why did you come to winter fur
[Music]
Jones the one to lead the fight against
the dead I know he is but he can't do it
alone
according to Samwell Tarly
he knows Jon Snow is destined to lead
the fight against the night king but
their work behind the scenes will be
just as vital Sam is exactly what brain
needs to find the answers they already
made quick work of figuring out Jon
Snow's real name and the fact that jon
is made up of Ice and Fire will most
likely play a big part in defeating the
night king as well it can't just be any
character that takes him down it has to
be someone or something very special and
finding out Jon as Ice and Fire might be
the first step in figuring all this out
it's clear that bran needs a bit of
guidance he can see all of history and
everything unfolding in the present day
but he doesn't always know where to look
Samwell Tarly can help him separate the
needles from the haystacks not just the
truth about Johnson as parents but also
how to defeat or even kill the night
king for good once you start to put all
the pieces together it becomes quite
clear that brain will have to find the
answers to stopping the night king in
according to uncle Benjen
he should be ready by the time the night
king gets there now the big question is
what the hell well bran see inside of
the weirwood net that could possibly
help him
could it have something to do with the
legendary sword Lightbringer was
Melisandre right this whole time only
she had her eyes set on the wrong person
at first we did see the ceremony she
held on the beach of Dragonstone where
stain has pulled the burning sword out
of the statues chest well Jon Snow have
to do something like this next season in
the ancient books it's written that a
warrior will draw a burning sword from
the fire
and that sword shall be Lightbringer
maybe brain stark will see something
like this instead of the weirwood net
then he will tell John this is what he
must do who really knows but all the
clues have already been laid out before
us we just have to know where to look
however some people say the night king
is not meant to die at all if history is
any proof the others were defeated in
the last battle for the dawn but keep in
mind they were defeated not killed this
is where the whole Ice and Fire duality
of the story comes into play the two
different ends of the spectrum it
doesn't matter if you put the scary
white walkers on one side and the
Magnificent dragons on the other Ice and
Fire still remain two sides of the same
coin
it's not going to be a battle between
good and evil there is no good or evil
it's going to be a battle between fire
and ice
many people believe Danny is a good
queen and the night king is an evil
monster but could they flip the script
in the end with the reveal that Danny is
not all good as she seems and the night
king is not pure evil even Danny's
right-hand man Jorah Mormont told us the
very same thing tempting to see your
enemies as evil all of them but there's
good and evil on both sides in every war
the priest he said it's very tempting to
see your enemies as evil but there's
good and evil on both sides of every war
that's ever fought Daenerys in the night
King are both only trying to do what
they feel they must however they have
one big common denominator they wreak
havoc and destruction wherever they go
ice and fire fire and ice some people
would say what is the point of making it
a Song of Ice and Fire if one of them is
really just gonna topple the other one
over where's the surprise element Fire
and Ice will clash but maybe the night
king and the Dragons just cancel each
other out and they both go back into
hibernation for hundreds or thousands of
years but in due time they could return
and wreak havoc all over again but let
me know what you think will happen
what possible answers can brain find
inside of the weirwood net is there some
perfect answer in killing the night king
or will he go back and look at how the
last hero and the children of the forest
and did the first long night let me know
what you think put your thoughts or
opinions down below in the comment
section also don't forget
about the giveaway there are only two
weeks left to enter using the link that
is down below in the description of the
video the winner will be able to pick
whichever shirt and size they would like
you can enter up to five different times
to increase your chances of winning good
luck everyone and I want to thank you
all for taking the time out of your day
to watch the video I really appreciate
that along with everyone who continues
to support the channel on patreon I hope
you all have a great day
I will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you